hey this is sad and low energy an
anti-vaccine organization called safe
minds with hoping to draw a link between
vaccines and autism so what did they do
they funded a long-term study that just
finished up unfortunately for them it
came back with results that they didn't
like which is that lo and behold
vaccines and autism aren't actually
linked the study took place over six
years it observed behavioral changes in
baby monkeys when they were given
vaccines the result of the study were
published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences and once
again science failed to show any link
between vaccines and autism the study
had 79 monkeys in six groups two groups
were given to the marisol vaccines user
vaccines with an antiseptic and an
antifungal agent two groups were given
MMR vaccines the common bag vaccine
against measles mumps and rubella and
two groups were given saline injections
as a sort of control the study found
that quote no behavioral changes were
observed in two vaccinated animals nor
were there neuropathological changes in
the cerebellum hippocampus or amygdala
this study does not support the
hypothesis that samaras all containing
vaccines and or the MMR vaccine play a
role in the etiology of autism after the
study released its results safe mine
said oh no no no the researchers were
biased they didn't do the study
correctly all that stuff here's part of
the statement that they posted to their
website saying quote the vaccine
primates study in question consisted of
multiple phases the second recent phase
purported to find no effect safe lines
has concerns about changes in the study
design protocol and analysis that may
have led to these contradictory results
we are in the process of collecting and
reviewing additional information
regarding this study I emphasize with
parents of children with autism but we
have to understand that humans have a
natural impulse to try to explain things
that aren't understood in simple and
convenient ways that's what anti-vaccine
activists do this is the motive that is
responsible for so many conspiracy
theories and I'm currently reading
Daniel Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and
Slow and many of the cognitive biases
and heuristics that he discusses lend
themselves to the type of thinking that
leads some humans to latch on to ideas
like vaccines cause autism I don't even
understand the internal logic of anti
Baxter's I mean is having your child
died from a preventable disease
preferable to living with autism and I
know that that's not a question that is
often asked of these individuals and
maybe in some cases it would be
considered sort of us pudding or
offensive but not vaccinating your child
puts them and society at substantial
risk unnecessary risk and despite what
Donald Trump says reminder the president
is maybe a vaccine autism conspiracy
theorist remember one of the tweets that
he sent out in 2012 autism rates through
the roof why doesn't the Obama
administration do something about dr.
inflicted us autism we lose nothing to
try how sad and low energy is it when
you fund a study and then it proves what
everybody else is telling you and then
you have to go out and denounce the
study that you funded as being not
credible right and it's clear that they
weren't having an honest approach at the
scientific method have to be able to
accept whatever this study comes up with
ya if you're not willing to take in
evidence that's contrary to your point
it's kind of like the Peter bogosian
method then your beliefs are not rooted
in evidence no and absolutely these
beliefs are not rooted in evidence
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum there's already a
thread about this there david pakman.com
slash reddit after the break our
investigation into gerrymandering
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
I glasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five day home try-on from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact ones
I started with the free at home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
three hundred dollars for prescription
glasses with Warby Parker they started
just 95 bucks mine cost that including
lenses and for every pair sold they give
a pair to someone in need so to try the
five pairs and support the david pakman
show go to Warby Parker trial com /t DPS